the Senate intelligence committees
former head of security is due in court
today accused of lying to the FBI about
talking with reporters 58 year-old James
Wolfe was arrested yesterday the FBI
says he was in regular contact with a
number of journalists the New York Times
says investigators secretly seized phone
and email records from one of its
reporters Jeff buguese is outside the
Justice Department Jeff good morning
good morning James Wolf's arrest comes
as the White House is cracking down on
leakers prosecutors say that will
falsely claim two FBI agents in an
interview in 2017 that he did not have
contact with reporters but according to
an indictment unsealed late Thursday
investigators say that he had repeated
contact with at least three reporters
between 2015 and 2017 Wolf's job as the
director of security for the Senate
Intelligence Committee gave him access
to classified information the New York
Times reported Thursday that
investigators secretly seized years
worth of phone and email records from
reporter Ally Watkins
The Times reports investigators did not
obtain the content of those messages the
time says Watkins had a 3-year personal
relationship with Wolfe before she began
working for the paper in 2017 now
Watkins denies that Wolfe gave her
classified information and her attorney
says the seizure of her data was in
their words disconcerting now this is
the first known incidents incidents that
fee Department of Justice under the
trump administration has seized a
reporter's data it is a tactic that the
Obama administration used in the past we
reached out to James Wolfe for a comment
we still haven't heard back if he is
convicted in this case he could get up
to 15 years behind bars
John Jeff Pegues force in Washington
thanks Jeff there's gonna be a lot more
coming out of that that added story yeah
absolutely what did they find on all
those seized records from the New York
Times reporter who had this relationship
with who are the other reporters exactly
right and the Justice Department does
not like take kindly to lying to the FBI
no it doesn't